european cars have yellow turn signals
american cars blink red in the european
union co2 emission standards for cars a
stricter than in the US but american
safety requirements are more rigorous
the differences are a stumbling block
for auto manufacturers they'd be the big
winners of the plan transatlantic free
trade zone take Ford the largest
American company in Germany then hat
matters CEO of Ford in Germany is an
avid supporter of a free trade agreement
it would benefit his company yesterday
Beckford font serves it would eliminate
import duties removing a burden of about
a billion euros a year Biden's second
technical standardization we could
develop and produce a single product
reducing complexity and lowering costs
and third in the area of testing and
permits one testing procedure and one
permit procedure would save a lot of
money he would reduce development times
and thus benefit consumers let's list
info Han su puta come one car with the
same parts for the whole global market
Ford's focus is already sold around the
world but the Mustang is available only
in the United States now a special
version of it is to arrive on European
shores in the opposite direction ford
wants to build new compact car engines
in the EU and export them to the US that
would create jobs in Europe the fans
upconverted virtuosic with a free trade
agreement economic growth would take off
because opportunities for companies
would grow in Europe in the United
States in it was a box in German
companies could compete in the US for
additional market shares there and
successful US companies could compete
here and have additional success
educatin would hit suzette six now for
josh often the agreement would create
the world's largest free trade zone with
more than 800 million people but it
would affect more than duties and
products European consumer protection
standards and labor law might be
harmonized with those of the United
States the metal workers and auto
industry union IG Metall and its
chairman detlev Etzel opposed the free
trade agreement via zeen till easily
think the risks are much greater we fear
that the plant agreement on protecting
investments enables investors to get
around state measures social policy and
consumer rights they could even sue the
taxpayers if their expectations for
profits are not fulfilled we fear that
standards will be caught in a race to
the bottom I met laughlin III understand
that skit for example investors might go
to court to challenge minimum wage laws
and laws protecting employees against
firings which were achieved at great
effort in Europe but the public isn't
even hearing what's really being
discussed in Brussels
they brought us for and such we need
transparency here negotiators on both
sides should state their goals the
Democratic public has to be able to take
part and see what's going on develop an
opinion and debate with the negotiators
but neither the American or the European
negotiators want that America can also
Vienna Funaro Podesta's hands up come
gets tons it's just not true that the
free trade agreement aims to limit
workers rights that is neat the file
that's employee rights existing in
Germany will be maintained in
deutschland diesters were the fighters
were heightened blab proponents say the
trade agreement will boost the EU
economy by half a percent and that would
take a decade the opponent's doubt this
prediction the mom kind of boutique we
don't make policy in Germany in Europe
for the benefit of three companies it's
not legitimate we don't need policies
that benefit a few while disadvantaging
many feet of it not if there are
obstacles to trade like import duties
they can be discussed bilaterally and
differently organized without such an
agreement al lunch break na keynesian to
stimulate trade in the economy but at
what price negotiations will continue at
least through 2015 for Europe a lot is
at stake